sea este de x igual a la raíz de 4 x 3 y
se hace el número que satisfaga el
teorema del valor medio para f en el
intervalo 1 menor o igual que x menor o
igual a 3 encuentran el valor de 0 así
que qué te parece si recordamos que
tiene que cumplirse para que satisfagan
el teorema del valor medio para f
bueno primero x igual hace es el punto
en donde la pendiente de la recta
tangente a la curva debe de ser igual a
la pendiente de la recta secante entre x
1 y x 3 es decir que si f prima deben
ponerlo con este color si f prima de c
es la pendiente de la recta tangente
cuando x balesem muy bien esto tiene que
ser igual
a la pendiente de la recta se decanten
que conecta a estos dos puntos
recuerda tenemos los puntos 1 1 y 3
efe de 3 ya después veremos cuánto valen
efe de 173 pero lo que quiero que veas
es que esto de aquí va a ser exactamente
igual que f3f de 3 - f1 ok y si a esto
lo dividimos entre 3 menos uno observa
que aquí me estoy tomando la pendiente
la pendiente de la recta secante
entre los puntos 1 1 y 3
efe de 3 y si quieres saber de una
manera visual de lo que estoy hablando
lo podemos ver así déjame ponerlo como
por aquí y mediante que éste es
x este es mi eje x y por aquí me tomo no
sé a 0 por aquí me tomo al 1 por aquí me
tomo al 2 y por aquí me tomo el 3 y
vamos a fijarnos en qué es lo que pasa
entre 1 y 3
así que por aquí imagínate que tomó al
punto 1 f 1 1
de uno bueno de hecho podemos saber
cuánto valen f1 si ponemos el valor de
uno aquí en esta función x igual a uno
me darían 4 por 1 es 4 - 3 es uno y la
raíz de uno es 1
entonces me quedaría el punto 11 muy
bien 1.1 y porque tengo el punto
3 efe de 3 y podemos ver cuánto es entre
3 y 4 por 3 es 12 12 339 entonces la
raíz del nueve es 3 perfecto tenemos el
punto 3,3
ahora bien imagínate que por aquí me
tomo una curva que se ve más o menos así
me tomo esta pulpa de aquí esta va a ser
mi curva y ahora imagínate que me voy a
fijar en la recta secante que pasa por
estos dos
entonces déjame poner bien a este punto
es más lo voy a poner con otro color a
este punto muy bien a este otro punto y
ahora vamos a aplicarnos en la pendiente
de la recta que conecta a estos dos
puntos se vería más o menos así una
recta que conecta a estos dos puntos muy
bien y lo que te dice el teorema del
valor medio es que existe una serie no
sé por aquí la cual al fijarnos en el
punto que toma en la curva
supongamos este de aquí déjame ver este
de aquí el cual más el punto se coma
fcc todavía no sabemos cuánto vale es
hacer si nos fijamos en este punto bueno
este punto cumple con una peculiaridad
la pendiente de la recta tangente a la
curva en este punto va a ser la misma
pendiente que toma la recta secante esta
recta de color anaranjado
que acabo de dibujar va a tener la misma
pendiente de hecho lo que nos piden
encontrar es este valor de cm es decir
buscamos un punto tal que la pendiente
de su recta tangente la curva la
pendiente de esta red está evaluada
claro en este punto al cm sea igual a la
pendiente en la recta que pasa por estos
dos puntos finales
bien pues vamos a encontrarse y para eso
esencialmente tenemos que resolver esta
ecuación que tengo aquí así que qué te
parece si primero calculamos f prima de
x y para eso voy a copiar aquí a fx que
es igual a quien bueno es igual a 4x
menos 34 x menos 3 pero en lugar de
poner la raíz cuadrada voy a poner a
esto elevado a la potencia 1
y así me va a ser mucho más fácil
derivar esta expresión que tengo aquí 4x
menos 3 sale un medio es lo mismo que la
raíz de 4 x 3 bien entonces vamos a ver
cuánto es
efe prima de x si observas f prima de x
va a ser igual
utilizando la regla de la potencia y
también las reglas de la cadena esto va
a ser igual a bueno primero tomémonos la
derivada de 4x menos 3 a la un medio con
respecto a 4x menos 3 y para eso este un
medio lo vamos a bajar multiplicando me
quedaría un medio que multiplica a 4x
menos 3 esto elevado en la potencia
menos un medio le quitamos 1 al
exponente ojo aquí estoy derivando
primero 4x menos 3 a la un medio con
respecto a 4x menos 3 pero ahora habrá
que multiplicar esto por la derivada de
4 x 3
respecto a x la derivada de 4x con
respecto a x es 4 y la derivada de menos
3 con respecto a x es cero así que
simplemente nos quedan cuatro libras y
cuatro por un médium es lo mismo que dos
y puedo decir ya que la derivada de x va
a ser lo mismo que 22 ya esto lo voy a
dividir entre la raíz de 4x menos 34 x
menos 3 aquí tengo 4 x menos 3 al a un
medio bueno es la raíz de 4 x 3 pero
como tengo este signo negativo entonces
va a pasar como nuestro denominador es
el signo negativo va a ser que se vaya
esa raíz de 4x menos 3 hacia abajo ok
entonces esto es entre prima de x pero
nosotros lo que queremos es f prima de s
así que qué te parece si sustituimos
hace en esta expresión entre prima de se
va a ser lo mismo que dos lo voy a poner
aquí
y que a su vez está dividido entre la
raíz cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de 4 cm
menos 3 y estoy sustituyendo a x por el
valor de ser y esto va a ser igual esto
va a ser igual a efe de 3 - f1 entre 3 -
1 pero efe de 3 ya no tenemos efe de 3
vale 3 porque recuerda 12 - 3 es 9 y la
raíz de 9 estrés así que me quedarían
que este de aquí vale 3 este de 1
también ya lo tenemos valía 1 así que lo
voy a poner aquí 1 y me queda
simplemente 3 - 1 entre 3 - 1 lo cuales
2 entre 2 y es exactamente lo mismo que
uno
entonces buscamos un punto entre 1 y 3
donde la derivada en ese punto es decir
la pendiente de la recta tangente sea
exactamente igual a 1 así que vamos a
ver si puedo resolver esto qué te parece
si primero multiplicamos de ambos lados
por bueno por esto que tengo acaba con
la raíz de 4 c menos 3 y así voy a
obtener que 2-2 es igual y de este lado
me quedaría la raíz la raíz de 4 cm
menos 3 lo único que hice fue
multiplicar de ambos lados por la raíz
de 4 c menos tres para poder quitarlo
del denominador en el lado izquierdo
y ahora qué te parece si el debut de
ambos lados al cuadrado para quitar esta
raíz voy a elevar de ambos lados al
cuadrado esta raíz con este cuadrado se
van y me queda que 44 es igual a 4 cm
menos 3 muy bien sumando 3 ambos lados
me queda que 7 es igual a 4 cm muy bien
y si ahora divido de ambos lados entre 4
déjame ponerlo por acá si habrá dividido
entre 4 de ambos lados me va a quedar
que se es igual a 7 cuartos a 7 cuartos
o es exactamente lo mismo que un entero
tres cuartos o lo podemos ver como 1.75
así que si observas por aquí no tenía
una mala aproximación por aquí está lo
es un poquito antes un poquito antes
tengo el valor de 1.75 y ya está
esta es mi respuesta correcta esto es lo
que nos pide el problema un valor de sé
que en este caso fue cercano a 2 y
espero que esto te haya dado una idea de
lo que tenemos aquí y de que el teorema
del valor medio dice que la pendiente de
la recta tangente en este valor de cm es
igual a la pendiente de la recta que
pasa por estos dos puntos por el punto 1
efe de 1 y por el punto 3 efe de 3